en nicaragua llevan por lo menos 16
opositores detenidos incluidos 4
precandidatos presidenciales que iban a
enfrentarse en las urnas con el
presidente daniel ortega pero ya están
fuera de la carrera electoral y todo por
un paquete de normas recientes que
incluye la llamada ley de soberanía esa
ley fue aprobada en último minuto el 21
de diciembre de 2020 una asamblea
nacional de mayoría sana
normativa dice que los traidores a la
patria no podrán optar a cargos de
elección popular el truco está en como
se define un traidor a la patria la ley
dice que es todo aquel que financie un
golpe de estado fomente actos
terroristas o que inciten a la
injerencia extranjera demande o aplauda
la imposición de sanciones contra
nicaragua también incluye a quienes
piden intervenciones militares y
bloqueos económicos en contra del país
desde que se discutió el temor era que
la ley sirviera para acallar a los
opositores y más cuando hace parte de un
paquete legislativo que incluye a la ley
de regulación de agentes extranjeros que
divide a los ciudadanos entre verdaderos
nicaragüenses y agentes extranjeros
o la ley de ciberdelitos conocida como
la ley mordaza por limitar el contenido
en internet y criminalizar el ejercicio
periodístico esas normas se estrenaron
con las detenciones recientes y con
ellas ha ganado daniel ortega
el objetivo es limpiar la cancha y
presentarse finalmente a unas elecciones
presidenciales el 7 de noviembre sin que
exista un competidor que sea capaz de
derrotar a ortega el paquete legislativo
que se aprobó entre octubre de 2020 y
febrero de 2021 también incluye una
reforma que amplía de 48 horas a 90 días
el tiempo de detención durante la
investigación
no hay debido proceso' acá se han
inventado procedimientos judiciales
única únicamente con el propósito de
amedrentarlos así las cosas la oposición
nicaragüense está cada vez más
debilitada mientras que el presidente se
fortalece